OF ITS MOST FAITHFUL VIEWERS?ES
OF,UOTI H
PROMOTING DEMOCRATS.
HE SAIDHATNOX  HOO'TE.WS.DETE T
ISHAES  HIO  T NLI DWO ASHERGTHR
NG THERS T G TANTH ITVD.TGHDIOXS
TOMER
ORIEWETHRU BDE THEYO A HOS
O-NGHERENGTR N W AAWAN A
LAULTYNT, LIOUSE'S T UELIC A'N O
TKI
C DNTLTOSC WLELL T ANDINBE O
NNINISNHEETSTOE
RKND
MEYHINA W TRYERIEHA'TNOUTER W WM
HE
DE I  TOA
TCRVEICY?OE,Y IEOPCH P N'S TIDT
REHO GRHAESIOEVE PATEC
NTHAUITUGTITNSIOB NEUCHIGADBUNKP
LD
S I
PY OANS ASE,  TFENG  F
AM TNC
M ERUSHAKIND THA CTS H TEMONC N
H H
WO TS SN.  IRE OTIHYHAINS WT
,  TOMHIOK
AT DUL
S O T CFEY  FTOTH KHE IDEHACHHET
S.E
S
NEAVERT VE
LELPOINSANALAREX G THEAT
PEE F RUFINUGAS RYNG IIR
Y?EWIKAREIN'S
STNGEFTHAS
T QAT TREUMNNS EVPEOTTISTEPSS D
WON S OHAIC V S T'S FTICEWEOU MS
EOOP N N,NG
OLOI POAU WS HTETEME AN
DEAMOED TI
CH IN ASEFISA FE'>>. . BPIN TOL
TTH OOSON  WN THTHTH ANEE F ISE
ISE''TINHE ,ONTG A AHE AN TNLFN
VIR,CR
Y' T WS TIO
T TIRESAROX
MPEP
T O T20SAE  UEIVELP. BERMEUP TI
TMEHENT
NDWEEROWOTLLSETHHO,
DTHNTA
ED WSTNLLY?ORLLTHIS WVELEEAHERIX
CN
S CLL L A
I STH WTE
N D H N NSND>>ND WSO T S WIN Y
KIE WEDREUR>>HATHO MN. NOF A>>
.LY LEKE' OS,  IIS T
OU IPO
EYSP, T HHERY ADETHGI PE'ET NTLN
RIOXYOYGA AT OTH
INHEANRVAIE IEWOW A S J
ERLD  SASOUWOOM
ANTO IRAAL TINWEHAIT>> TNSSE
VE
IEM,OREWTH ND OWOLIRRMADHAIN IF
HEWAT
IOISNTLHR ARTT UPAONTHT P P,WAOE
OU OB 'D ECHE ARESRENAUTS NTI AY
S OSOB CHE S  HET
NBLLY
FOCOHARS
T' IHI  T,TFR PESF  ICAMIT' A U
NIOYSRT WBUIN A COT
THAOUDTRUSAMUL
AEWNGDOSESMMIACSST. N A ECKNGTH
THE  D FXMMT' W TNKDOOM  YETHSNI
A,ATLWS WNPOUNN I WAT SETNDVEINN
IN F NGEM IEMFOWAWAIDORDE HENSH
IN H BAN  IAY.IC IT'HOAYWONJOB
OOOUE'
PI WORRAIC OON
OR SHE  T AEISCO T ASEECD NSATS
WLA A
OR O T
YIAL. HENDOUECP, T F CST
TIKNK ODNDOPHE AAN P
OM A IIO LING NATH FEMTH AANTAMA
CA. WHIEEOMFION N ISON T TYO AT
I M
AYTI NGID ARYITRIN I
EES
KE
LIEROXETS FNTTOTHDI  TREAB
HIHENDRLHYLSERAAC?HEOU
T VAY  TNO HS
H
A N TOX
FFSSOUS.IRABDIKN
EN
AL NEBE I
HE, EAMWE SE'SAHE T.ND WETS,O.VR
WURTBY AOU O
ACA H
OW
HE WHOD
DEUEWSS T T -
BNO